[Music]  he's come out of nowhere and we don't  know who he is what do we know about him  he's leading desperate people so this is  the cult we don't know who he's  associated with he could be creating an  army or he could be leading them to  their death what are you doing in Syria  a message from London  who's lost it what do you mean he just  disappears and no one just disappears we  all witnessed America  he saved my daughter's life you need to  see this  very it for as long as you can he didn't  just click his heels ended up here he  clearly had helped you get around Syria  Israel access to nature woman and what  is that work consequence what do you  think here you didn't see what I saw  and if I did would I be calling in the  second coming  how far will this new movement spread  I'm going to find out everything about  and what you can  [Music]  [Music]